Okay, because the reaction in the infant is
so severe, there's probably no lactase produced at all,
due to some kind of significant deletion maybe
of the TATA box and the promoter region. If
it was just the enhancer, we might expect
some diminished lactase activity, but we wouldn't expect it
to be missing completely. Severe lactose intolerance suggested
that we have almost no lactase available, so this
probably means a problem in the promoter, not the enhancer.
There were lot of different ways that you could have responded
to this question, to the why part of the question
and what I hope you did is spent some time planning
out your answer and writing it out. Now there's an
okay to a best level of answering this question, in my
opinion and an okay response, which isn't very good, and I
hope you put more than this is, the promoter is mutated.
Meaning that you were able to select
correctly that it's the promoter and just indicate
that you think that's where the mutation is
but that's not much of an explanation. The
next best answer ranked here as good would be saying that the promoter
likely has a mutation in the consensus sequence, preventing
transcription and causing the symptoms. So understanding that the actual
mutation itself is happening in a sequence, it's
a consensus, and it blocks transcription all together. Still
it leaves a little bit to be desired. A
better answer would be to say that the TATA-box,
right, which we know is consensus sequence is
likely mutated which prevents transcription factors from binding right.
We know that there are transcription factors that bind
and make transcription happen. This results in no lactase,
which explains the severe phenotype. A change in
the enhancer, would have less of an effect.
So you not only understand, right, that the
TATA-Box is crucial to the effectiveness of the
promoter, but you realize that the enhancer isn't
really doing that much as far as absolute
control, right? It can boost levels, right, but
it's not going to essentially take all the transcription away,
as we see in the case of the infant. And the best possible answer here is to
be pretty comprehensive and to say that the consensus
TATA- box of the promoter is likely deleted or
significantly altered as a result critical transcription factors can't
bind and transcription doesn't occur, so we get no
lactase protein. And this would explain the severe phenotype
better than a change or deletion in the enhancer
region, whose alleles seem only to effect lactase presistence
into adulthood. What I'd really like for you to
do is, look at your answer from the previous
video screen and I want you to compare it to
these answers here and then select the check box
here that you think best evaluates how you answered
the question. if you think you were only okay
check the okay box, if you think you were best
check the best box. And there are boxes in-between these answers that
you can check as well if you think your answer is somewhere
in the middle. Go ahead and do that comparison now and then
select which box you think fairly assesses your answer to this question.